IN A COUPLE OF HOURS FROM YOU,
THE WAGNER PRIVATE MILITARY
COMPANY IS PULLING OUT OF
BAKHMUT.
HERE'S WHAT WE'RE LEARNING.
AFTER MONTHS OF FEROCIOUS
FIGHTING IN BAKHMUT, THE CHIEF
OF RUSSIA'S PRIVATE ARMY,
WAGNER, IS SAYING HIS FIGHTERS
ARE EXHAUSTED AND WILL
WITHDRAWAL.
>> Translator: WE WILL BE
LEAVING BAKHMUT AND THE RUSSIAN
DEFENSE MINISTRY WILL BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR IT.
WE'RE LEAVING TO FIELD CAMPS TO
TRAIN AND REST.
>> Reporter: PRIGOZHIN CLAIMS TO
CONTROL ALL OF BAKHMUT WHICH THE
UKRAINIANS DISPUTE.
HE ALSO ACKNOWLEDGES LOSING
AROUND 20,000 FIGHTERS IN THE
BRUTAL MONTH'S LONG CAMPAIGN,
EVEN AS THE U.S. AND UKRAINE SAY
THE FIGURES ARE MUCH HIGHER,
POSSIBLY UP TO 100,000.
DESPITE THE ALLEGED VICTORY IN
BAKHMUT, IN A BOLD COMMENT,
PRIGOZHIN SAYS VLADIMIR PUTIN'S
WAR IS NOT ACHIEVING ITS CORE
OBJECTIVE OF WEAKENING UKRAINE.
>> Translator: HOW DID WE
DEMILITARIZE IT?
NOW IT TURNS OUT THAT WE ON THE
CONTRARY HAVE MILITARIZED
UKRAINE.
I THINK THAT THE UKRAINIANS
TODAY ARE ONE OF THE STRONGEST
ARMIES.
>> Reporter: PRIGOZHIN HAS LONG
BEEN ATTACKING RUSSIA'S ELITES,
ACCUSING THEM OF BEING CORRUPT,
LAZY AND NOT INVOLVED IN THE
WAR.
NOW HE FEARS CONTINUING LOSSES
ON THE BATTLEFIELD COULD LEAD TO
A REVOLUTION IN RUSSIA.
>> Translator: ALL OF THIS CAN
END LIKE IN 1917 WITH A
REVOLUTION WHEN FIRST THE
SOLDIERS RISE UP AND AFTER THAT,
THEIR LOVED ONES RISE UP.
>> Reporter: ALL THIS AS THE WAR
IS INCREASINGLY AFFECTING
RUSSIA'S HOMELAND.
RUSSIA'S DEFENSE MINISTRY TODAY
RELEASING VIDEO OF WHAT IT SAYS
WAS A FAILED ATTACK ON A RUSSIAN
WARSHIP USING UNMANNED
SPEEDBOATS.
UKRAINE HAS NOT COMMENTED ON THE
INCIDENT.
AND AFTER THE BRAZEN CROSS
BORDER RAID, BY ANTI-PUTIN
RUSSIAN FIGHTERS, WHICH UKRAINE
SAYS IT WAS NOT INVOLVED IN, BUT
RUSSIA BLAMES ON KYIV, VOWING
REVENGE.
>> Translator: WE WILL CONTINUE
TO RESPOND TO SUCH ACTIONS BY
UKRAINIAN MILITANTS PROMPTLY,
AND EXTREMELY HARSHLY.
>> Reporter: BUT PRIGOZHIN SAYS
THE ATTACK SHOWS THE RUSSIAN
MILITARY IS INCAPABLE OF
PROTECTING THE COUNTRY'S
BORDERS.
>> Translator: SABOTAGE AND
RECONNAISSANCE FORCES CALMLY
ENTER RUSSIA AND MARCH,
UPLOADING VIDEOS, DRIVING THEIR
TANKS, ARMORED INFANTRY
VEHICLES, WHERE'S THE SAFEGUARD
THAT THEY WILL NOT ENTER MOSCOW?
>> Reporter: OF COURSE WE HAVE
BEEN REPORTING ABOUT THE ONGOING
FEUD BETWEEN PRIGOZHIN, AND IT
WAS NO SURPRISE TO HAVE HIM
CRITICIZE SHOYGU, BUT HE ALSO
CALLED FOR SHOYGU TO BE REPLACE
LD N. LIGHT OF THE INCIDENT IN
BELGRADE, THERE ARE A LOT OF
PEOPLE ASKING IN RUSSIA HOW
EXACTLY IT WAS POSSIBLE THAT THE
MILITARY WAS NOT ON SCENE AS
THAT CROSS BORDER RAID WAS
TAKING PLACE,